[Music]
be afraid be very afraid that black
badge models are the dark side of
rolls-royce dark direct and powerful
spawned by the makers own tuning
attempts to balance individual luxury
and outright bombast
husbands are Chester I know that's what
more could a modern man or woman want
than health wealth and coolness
so the sensible super-rich don't buy
just any rolls-royce they plumped for
the black batch the bad boy among
British luxury cars even the Emily
statuette is black there's a black
grille and lots of carbon and black
tailpipe finishers and Rolls Royces are
known for being palaces on wheels but
the black badge version seems more like
a rugged fortress in the Scottish
Highlands
but rolls wasn't content just to paint
everything black they've also been at
work on the engine and transmission
after all that's what tuning is all
about
[Music]
aside from the smart carbon-fiber
composite rims the profile hasn't
changed on request the chrome window
frames can be blackened too at a total
length of 5 meters 28 this mobile castle
weighs in at a hefty 2440 kilograms
trunk capacity is 470 liters
[Music]
cabone father carbon-fibre replaces wood
trim aluminum house chrome and matte
black dominates the interior inside the
instrument panel is striking seal with
six layers of clear varnish hand
polished to a fine gloss after being
left to dry for a full 72 hours as soon
as he starts off Ryan Holtz census that
the steering is more direct and the
dampers are firmer istant at 465
kilowatts the right black badge is the
most potent rolls to date with its power
further enhanced by its 870 Newton
metres of torque fuel consumption is
rated at fourteen point six liters per
100 kilometers it accelerates from 0 to
100 km/h in 4.5 seconds
that's divine Oh discovers the jerks
typical of fast starts and stops are
absent the low setting directs the
automatic transmission to start shifting
only after the engine reaches 6000 revs
the gas pedal responds more
spontaneously so that two and a half
tons are pretty nimble but always a
rolls-royce just as a weight lifter is
not the ideal gymnast a rules limo can
hardly double as a sports car the
standards of self-assured elegance
combined with uncompromising luxury are
defining for the brand so the suspension
can only get so stiff and the exhaust
only so loud but there's a good reason
to dress the right in black with an
average age of 46 today's rules buyers
aren't the youngest and they tend to
want a chauffeur the best way to appeal
to a younger target group is with a
sporty ER model that reflects their
lifestyle Rolls Royces darker side has
its powers of attraction a black badge
marks its owner as a cutting edge style
conscious and individualistic person but
anyone who spends over three hundred
thousand euros on a car has never been
normal maybe exceptional is the best
description